we're also celebrating trailblazers as
part of our black history month coverage
and this morning we're focusing on two
groundbreaking chefs chef alexander
smalls is a james beard award winner and
he's the force behind two critically
acclaimed restaurants in harlem the
former opera singer i know burst onto
the restaurant scene in the 1990s
meanwhile chef kwame anawachi sold candy
on the subway to pay for his first
catering business the author and former
top chef competitor has since opened
five restaurants and they caught up with
each other recently at chef alexander's
new york city apartment
all right i got you going
[Music]
[Applause]
i grew up looking up to you knowing
about your story in your restaurant my
mom's a chef so she always she is you
know she she made sure that i was privy
to all that came before me and it's so
awesome for me to be sitting down with
you this is what we do
where did it all start
i need to know because i know everyone
else wants to know where did it start so
i grew up in spartanburg south carolina
you know it really started like
everything else
in my mother's kitchen when i was
growing up segregation was still very
much alive so we stayed home a lot it's
funny you say that because
the reason why i even cook today is
because my family grew up in the south
like my ancestors and there was so much
segregation
to the point
they didn't go out to eat right but we
had places in the back of our homes
convenience stores absolutely juke
joints yes rib shacks fish fries
exactly so my family always ran the
restaurants in whatever small town they
were in and that's why i come from a
long line of restaurants out of
necessity
[Music]
i grew up in the bronx right here in new
york city
my mother was a huge influence in me and
also just new york city being a melting
pot as it is of all these different
cultures and cuisines and she had a
catering company that she operated from
the house and if i wanted to have the
lights on you know i needed to help out
you know she threw me in all hands on
all hands on deck at all times
i started to veer off from the wrong
path
i started to stay out late when i was
supposed to come home i was also a
a pretty bad kid when i was younger and
my parents uh
yeah there you go my parents told me i
was going on a two-week vacation to
nigeria
and they left me there for two years in
order to learn respect but it shaped me
into the man that i am today because
you know we had to like kill our own
livestock you know i was really able to
appreciate my ingredients and where they
came from and the why behind it that's
what led me here to today is just
wanting to really convey the act of
hospitality in every single well that's
where you found your power and your
strength you mean you realized that what
you did in that kitchen you could put it
on a plate and people would be blown
away i mean because those of us who cook
those of us in the restaurant industry
it's like a drug i've done five
restaurants and a 22 000 square foot
food hall
yeah and still i'm making plans for more
restaurants for sure and i've opened up
five restaurants before i even turned
30.
you know and there are more on the
horizon
rolling on a river you were an opera
singer yes how did you go from an opera
singer to being this world-renowned chef
well of course
carme i'm still
an operation
i haven't heard you sing yet
[Music]
i wanted to really be the first
african-american male who was prominent
on the operatic scene i decided that i
had gone as far
as i could with opera and that i really
needed to be in control of my destiny i
couldn't own an opera house but i could
own a restaurant
[Music]
so that was the transition and so i set
out to open
what i felt would be the most important
restaurant
with respect to who we were as african
americans and that was cafe beulah and
then i opened sweet ophelias
shortly after that okay and then i
opened the shoebox cafe
you had one of the most
premier restaurants period
african-american or not yeah
but at the time there weren't a lot of
black chefs cooking food
at your level but also with your
confidence
you've had a long running
relationship with top chef yeah kwame i
like dish a lot i think the flavor is
really fantastic on both sides of the
table literally literally tell me about
that you know for me it was amazing
being so young and having this platform
great for my career it gave me so much
exposure and then you know fast forward
to this moment being on the other side
of the table as a judge table turn
pretty i think your stew is good it has
some depth of flavor
what do you have to say to the next
generation of chefs coming up that are
young black and gifted
ownership ownership ownership
it has made all the difference in my
life be present be intentional roar like
a lion
that's what i would tell you i love that
what are you cooking um well i've made
dessert i'm so proud of what you've been
able to accomplish i mean because you
more than than most understand what it
is to be a trailblazer you had a fine
dining establishment in your early 20s
that was attended by everybody that was
anybody including the president and i
look at you as someone who has picked up
the mantle
i basically
felt very strongly about making sure
that people understood what the
african-american kitchen was all about
you know and then you come along and
continue the conversation in an
extraordinary way which is our common
ground but i think we both have become
activists in our pursuit of uh expanding
the table for the african and
african-american kitchen
also like i think we're
we're just trying to keep the culture
alive in any way possible and that's why
we put ourselves so much on a plate
i've tasted uh chef alexander smalls
cooking he is really really really good
now i want to try chef kwame yeah just
looking at the pictures on the screen i
know that his mouths are watering here
so good delicious sandwiches i wonder
what they cooked together that night i
know that that dinner table i also love
what chef alexander says yeah roar like
a lion intentional that's all good
own ownership gotta have a piece very
cute
and he's got a beautiful singing voice
too special shout out to you shannon
louis brand who produced that piece we
say this all the time it's very
difficult to do those with no track and
have it make sense but shannon always
hits it out yes she always does well
done again shannon